محمود كيف يرى الخبراء فرص الهجوم البري
على غزه نعم هذا ما يسمى بالحرب غير
المتناظره في العلوم العسكريه حرب المدن
هي من اصعب الحروب التي يمكن لجيش نظامي
ان يدخلها على سبيل المثال عندما يدخل
الجيش النظامي الى مدينه ما فانه سيواجه
قوات لا يعلم ما هو لون لباسها العسكري من
اين ستظهر اين هي المباني الى اخره
الخبراء يشيرون ويقيسون على ما حدث في
الفلوجه كان هناك نحو 300000 نسمه 50,000
مبنى وكانت عمليه صعبه جدا للقوات
الامريكيه في ذلك الوقت واشار الخبراء
وقاسوا على غزه الان هناك اكثر من خمس
اضعاف ال عدد السكان في غزه هناك كتل
سكنيه اكبر بكثير ايضا هناك يضاف الى ما
كان في الفلوجه شبكه انفاق معقده جدا
وبالتالي ستكون العمليه البريه اصعب بكثير
اذا ما قرنت بتلك العمليه بحسب رايه